this video is for
trap doors in pepper panic saga that
goes along with our trap doors guide
to basically explain them, they are pretty
straightforward so to explain
how they work.  this is level 187
and it's pretty simple in the way
they're set up
you can see at the bottom we have three
entrance
trap doors and at the top we have three
exits
trap doors or so the entrance ones have
little blue arrows on the top and the
exits have little red
arrows at the bottom and that shows that
goes in here it comes out there
these men their own order they're not
really confusing at all
I'm and if you read the guide you know
that by making matches underneath them
that's how we get them to open up and
transfer your papers if you've ever
played
candy crush home you're probably
familiar with these are reading
the me say they look like this and candy
crush on this
level there connected crossways so
basically we have entry here
exit here itself we make a match down
here
these kids move that way so you can move
on
for more important place to the other
like that
they work pretty much the same way here
that you know they look a little
different
but overall pretty much the same concept
so
from a couple matches
see nothing moved through the trapdoor
there because we don't know open up a
space below
I'm the same thing here
match over here nothing will happen we
basically have to set up a match in the
left-hand side here
so that we can moved from the words and
I we can make this morn
this is getting her miss gonna move
three papers
here and then watch how these horns
and see that they are moved
this paper stayed behind so they are
moved basically to tell
through the door know this is a4 paper
match
so keep an eye on where these are at No
and this is gonna clear out three
so this one is going to move them that's
correct
that would also create a shock waves so
you can see they cleared up the whole
call this is another 13
3 ever made move in their own and
that's pretty much all there is to it
arm
on a level like this you can see that
we have statues here
so only make a match on this side you
know we know we can get a hit there
if we didn't want them to move around
like they were trying to start a chain
reaction
where this one's track then we makin me
outside row
on this side or on the side or
here's well
so used to him stackers up in the middle
still
they'll stay relatively a place in his
kennel one or the other and it's cool
world that's the basic idea ever
on some levels it's a little bit more
complicated phone
on this morn they're kinda blocked by
the cages
in the beginning or we make a match a/c
in in boxes are here
and here those and up
down at the bottom usually a good and
then you can have to look around because
these or entry trap doors
but the exits are at the top when I
first played the service live where they
go away from all this
they come into this to this column so
thats that's pretty much all there is to
it i mean they're they're fairly simple
or muncher in later levels will get a
little bit more complicated but
everything you need to know is in our
guide
so if you have any questions leave a
comment and we'll get back to you
hope this helps understand how they work
thanks